[Música]
entre ustedes que me escuchan y yo que
les hablo lo único que podemos compartir
es el abismo que nos separa
dijo alguna vez georges bataille un gran
filósofo francés que quiere decir que
compartimos lo único que compartimos es
el abismo que nos separa que no tenemos
nada en común entre nosotros que somos
extraños por ejemplo ahora yo nada sé de
ustedes y ustedes nada saben de mí y sin
embargo estamos aquí reunidos más de
cuatro mil personas en este anfiteatro
como hacían los griegos reunidos
alrededor de un viejo rito el de la
palabra compartida nos reúne un rito
humano demasiado humano como diría
nietzsche el rito de la conversación
ese rito expresa quizá el porqué de la
filosofía el amor por la sabiduría
porque solo sabemos que no sabemos nada
como decía sócrates y nos reunimos para
desandar ese camino ese camino que es el
camino del no saber movidos por la
ignorancia por suerte somos ignorantes y
tenemos sed de conocimiento que es una
sed compartida que es la sed que nos
reúne hoy aquí quizás no haya compartir
más genuino que es hacer que ese abismo
que nos separa
quizás ese abismo no sea tal y tengamos
mucho más en común de lo que creíamos
quizás esa nada que tenemos en común no
sea otra cosa que la sed de conocimiento
que nos atraviesa fuese haced la que me
llevó a estudiar filosofía a transitar
un camino como el del conocimiento que
siempre se mueve entre la carencia del
no saber y la aparente plenitud de lo
que queremos alcanzar entonces me
pregunto tenemos algo en común o lo
único que compartimos es el abismo que
nos separa en el abismo que nos separa
compartimos algo nuestra ignorancia y
algo incluso más profundo nada sabemos
el uno del otro nada sabemos de los que
nos precedieron nada sabemos incluso de
nosotros mismos la historia nuestra
historia no es otra cosa que la búsqueda
de una única constante no estar solos
nacemos vivimos y morimos por qué no
atravesados por una soledad constitutiva
y el mundo no es otra cosa que una
inmensidad hecha de ausencia escribió
alguna vez dolina en medio de su
inmensidad estamos nosotros solos pero
queremos no estarlo es justamente la
soledad la que nos permite saciar esa
sed por conocer es hacer por explorar lo
real esa sed se sacia da2 se sacia en
comunidad como ocurre con la amistad
como ocurre con el amor como ocurre con
el conocimiento es la ignorancia la que
nos iguala y es la potencia de la
ignorancia la que nos lleva a la
búsqueda de lo común a no estar solos es
porque asumimos nuestra ignorancia que
estamos en esa búsqueda y esta búsqueda
nos humaniza esta búsqueda nos redime
esta búsqueda expresa una verdad
profunda ese abismo que compartimos es
la profunda ignorancia que todos los que
estamos hoy aquí compartimos todos somos
igual de ignorantes en lo que respecta a
los temas realmente importantes o acaso
alguien tiene una respuesta definitiva
para el amor
alguno de nosotros podría dar una
definición última de la vista de la
filosofía que nació allá lejos y hace
tiempo en grecia
quizás no tiene otra función
imprescindible para nuestra vida en
común que encontrarle un sentido a una
existencia atravesada por la soledad por
el desamor en definitiva por la ausencia
sabemos que el cuento no termina bien
algo sabemos el resto lo ignoramos y que
ignoramos lo que vendrá por suerte lo
ignoramos y esa ignorancia esa
ignorancia compartida es quizá lo único
que podemos compartir por eso debemos
hacer de la carencia una virtud y de la
ausencia una positividad no debemos
tener miedo de revelar nuestra aparente
ausencia de conocimiento digo aparente
porque la conciencia de nuestra
ignorancia es un gesto de verdadera y
profunda sabiduría no debemos temer
preguntar una y otra vez si hay algo que
no entendemos entonces si algo nos
iguala profundamente como seres humanos
eso que nos iguala es la ignorancia la
ignorancia nos iguala de manera absoluta
la ignorancia nos iguala de manera
radical y esa igualdad
qué es la ignorancia es el motor de
nuestro conocimiento es el motor de
nuestro desarrollo es aquello que nos
permite a partir del encuentro a partir
de un encuentro como verde como este
a partir de la experiencia comunitaria
del estudio de la investigación correr
el horizonte de lo real volvernos en
definitiva mejores personas por eso la
experiencia del conocimiento es una
experiencia que nos humaniza que nos
acerca
si la filosofía tiene todavía hoy alguna
función será la de enseñarnos a medirnos
con el tamaño de nuestra ignorancia
porque como dice un amigo cuando el
juego termina el rey y el peón vuelven
al mismo cajón
entonces juguemos mientras podamos que
nuestra ignorancia y nuestro tiempo
presente así lo requieren
juguemos hoy aquí reunidos intentemos
que este juego entonces transforme
nuestras vidas pues lo único que
compartimos es el abismo que nos separa
[Aplausos]
[Música]